Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Yujal. Ich bin der DN-Sabendars auf dieser Station und möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie einverstanden? Ja.
Bevor wir Ihren aktuellen Beschwörden kommen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hanne-Lohre Walter.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Namen bestabieren?
Ja, Hanne-Lohre schreibt sich Ha-A-N-N-E-L-O-R-E. Hanne-Lohre, ich bin eine Frau.
Okay.
Der Nachname Walter, W-A-L-T-E-R.
Okay, Frau Walter, wie alt sind Sie?
55 Jahre.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 21. Mai 1968.
168.
Ja.
Okay, darf ich fragen, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
1,61 Meter.
Ja.
180 Kilo.
Okay, Frau Walter, was wird Sie zu uns?
Ja, seit 2 Stunden fühle ich mich gar nicht gut.
Da ist mir schlecht, ich habe Übelkeit und habe auch einmal erbrochen.
Und ich habe so ein starkes Druckgefühl so oben im Bauch und hinterm Brustbein.
Sie haben uns starken Brust schmeißen, oder?
Ja, mehr Druck.
Druckgefühl im Bauch und hinter dem Brustbein.
Oberbauch und hinter dem Brustbein.
Und gleichzeitig haben Sie auch Schmerzen, oder haben Sie nur Druckgefühl?
Ja, auch etwas Schmerzen, aber Hauptsache ist ein starker Druck.
Okay, haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, so etwas Luftnot habe ich auch.
Aber dieses Druckgefühl und die Übelkeit, das steht im Vordergrund.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie Herzstraßen, Herzstolpen?
Ja, ich habe bemerkt, dass der Puls etwas unregelmäßig war.
Okay, Strahl und Bischemmerzen, irgendwo hinaus.
Vielleicht so ein bisschen nach oben, Richtung Hals, aber am meisten sind Sie hinter dem Brustbein und dem Oberbauch.
Wir sind auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei es ein sehr leichter, stärkster Schmerz ist.
Ja, ich würde sagen 5 bis 6.
Okay, Frau Walter, ich würde gerne unsere Geschebrech unterbrechen und ich würde gerne Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja.
Okay, ich kontrolliere Ihre Puls- und Sauerstoffzittikung.
Ich möchte Ihnen auch eine EKG einschließen.
Okay, Frau Walter, wir können weitermachen.
Haben Sie Zotbrennen?
Nein, manchmal habe ich Zotbrennen, aber heute nicht besonders viel.
Aber manchmal habe ich das schon, aber jetzt nicht schlimm. Heute ist das nicht toll.
Okay, dritten Ihre Beschwörung bei der Belastung oder auch in Ruhe auf?
Ja, das ist jetzt ja erst seit 2 Stunden und das war so direkt beim Frühstück.
Da habe ich mich nicht groß belastet, aber so vor einigen Wochen hatte ich so etwas Ähnliches schon mal.
Aber das war nicht so stark.
Wie viele Stunden oder Minuten hat damals diese Beschwörden gedauert?
Auch so 2, 3 Stunden.
Auch 3 Stunden.
Okay, wissen Sie, was hat sich diese Beschwörden ausgelöst?
Ich habe ja beim Frühstück gesessen und da wurde es plötzlich so, dass ich dieses Druckenfühl kriege, die Übelkeit kriege.
Das war beim Frühstück.
Was haben Sie beim Frühstück gegessen?
Normalerweise. Ich esse morgens immer eine Scheibe Toastbrot und eine Tasse Tee trinke ich.
Ich Frühstücke normalerweise nicht viel.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen nicht.
Nur dieser Druck, auch im Oberbauch, Brustbein und hier an den Rippen oben, da ist richtiger Schmerz im Bauch, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder treten Sie hin und wieder auf?
Nein, die sind eigentlich jetzt immer da.
Und tritt die Atemnot nur bei Belastung auch in Ruhe auf?
Ja, ich habe mich seitdem das angefangen hat. Vor 2 Stunden habe ich mich gar nicht groß belastet, habe ich mich nicht getraut.
Ich habe ruhig im Sessel gesessen und als das nicht besser wurde, sind wir dann hier in die Klinik gefahren.
Sie haben gut gemacht. Haben Sie Ihre Bescheiden im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert?
Nein, die sind ziemlich leicht geblieben.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenäumt wie Medikamente?
Mein Mann ist ja herzkrank und hatte so ein Spray.
Er hat gesagt, probier mal dieses Spray aus und das habe ich in den Mund gesprüht.
Ich glaube, es ist danach etwas besser geworden, aber nur etwas.
Ein bisschen hat das ja auch schon.
Aber eben nicht ausreichend.
Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Walter?
Nein.
Stülphorosp nach Schweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, ist Ihnen momentan übel, auch schwindelig?
Ja.
Und einmal haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Einmal habe ich erbrochen.
Das war so direkt nach dem Frühstück sozusagen.
Da war eben wieder das, was ich gerade gegessen habe, ist dann wieder rausgekommen.
Toastbrot und der Tee.
Okay. Können Sie bitte erklären, wie sieht die Erbrochen aus?
Ja, das war eben Toastbrot, das, was ich gerade vorher gegessen hatte.
Reste essen.
Ja, ja, Reste essen.
Aber es war nicht irgendwie andere Farbe, kein Blut oder so.
Okay.
Haben Sie Hüsten?
Ja, ich habe etwas chronischen Hüsten, weil ich rauche.
Seit wann haben Sie Hüsten?
Ja, immer mal wieder schon in den letzten Jahren.
Mein Mann sagt, mein Arzt sagt, das ist Raucherhüsten.
Raucherhüsten, okay.
Und haben Sie dabei auch Auswurf bemerkt?
Manchmal kommt ein bisschen Schleim raus, aber der sieht vielleicht so weislich aus.
Manchmal ein bisschen gelb, aber ich schaue mir den Schleim oft nicht an.
Okay, Frau Walter.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewirsch abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Ach, ich habe mich wiegt jetzt ja 82 kg, das ist ja viel zu viel, sagen alle.
Nein, das ist schon mehr.
In den letzten Jahren habe ich ziemlich Gewicht zugenommen.
Sagen wir mal, in den letzten zehn Jahren habe ich so 12 kg zugenommen.
Aber abgenommen habe ich in letzter Zeit nicht.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Ja, der ist sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ich muss in der Regel zweimal nachts auf die Toilette Wasser lassen.
Tagsüber ist das soweit in Ordnung.
Stuhlgang ist regelmäßig, das habe ich keine Probleme.
Können Sie gut schlafen, einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, eigentlich ganz gut.
Sie müssen in der Nacht mindestens zweimal auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja, zweimal muss ich auf die Toilette gehen,
weil ich abends trinke, ich abends noch relativ viel Mineralwasser und Tee.
Ja, zweimal.
Wie viele Kissen brauchen Sie zum Schlafen, Herr Frau Walter?
Mindestens ein Kissen, manchmal noch ein kleines dazu.
Leiden Sie vor Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck, der wird es meldet, oder erhöht der Blutfette?
Was Sie genannt haben, habe ich alles.
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck?
Seit wann haben Sie?
Seit ca. 12 Jahren.
Da nehme ich ein Medikament ein.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Das heißt, Moment, kann die Satan, 8 steht dahinter.
8 Milligramm.
Einmal eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Gut.
Und haben Sie noch Diabetes mellitus?
Ja, also Zucker habe ich seit 8 Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch eine Tablette Medformin.
850 steht dahinter.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Dann haben Sie hohe Blutfette und hohe Scholesterin.
Dann nehme ich auch eine Tablette ein.
Welche Medikamente?
Was ist das?
Ich nachschauere, Roseau, was das heißt.
Roseau, was das heißt.
20 steht dahinter.
20 Milligramm.
Und einmal Abend, oder?
Einmal abends, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen noch andere Vorerkrankungen bekannt, Frau Walter?
Ja, vor drei Jahren wurde ich zum ersten Mal meine Netzhaut behandelt.
Da hat der Augenarzt festgestellt, das kommt wohl vom Zucker,
dass meine Netzhaut Schaden hat.
Und da wurde ich schon zweimal gelasert.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und glauben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich bin operiert worden.
Als Kind hatte ich blind am Operation.
Und vor sechs Jahren wurde meine Gallenblase entfernt wegen Gallensteinen.
Vor sechs Jahren wegen Gallenstein und als Kind war ich in der Oper.
Ich weiß nicht genau, acht oder neun Jahre alt.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, keine anderen Operationen.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen allerginen bekannt oder unverträglich,
gegen Medikamente oder Nehrungsmittel?
Ich bin nicht bekannt.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen über Ihre Gewohnheit stellen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche seit ungefähr 25 Jahren, 20 Jahren,
ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel pro Tag.
20 oder 25?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Aber nach der Geburt der Tochter habe ich angefangen zu rauchen.
Also 25 Jahre ungefähr, nicht ganz 25 Jahre.
Okay, 25 Jahre, halbe Packung Zigaretten.
Ja, wie Sie wissen, ist diese Zigaretten ein bisschen viel.
Ja.
Sie sollen aufhören oder resurdieren.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen aufhören.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es ist.
Meine Tochter sagt das auch.
Aber es fällt mir schwer davon, unterzukommen.
Ja, wir können auch dafür Ihnen helfen, wenn Sie wollen.
Okay, ich überlege mir das.
Okay, gerne.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol, Frau Walter?
Nein, ich vielleicht einmal in der Woche,
zweimal in der Woche trinke ich ein Glas Wein.
Ich trinke nicht jeden Tag Alkohol.
Ein Glas Wein.
Ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie bitte nicht, das ist eine angenehme Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und haben Sie auch nicht gehabt?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Walter?
Ich bin Bankangestellte.
Hoffen Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, nein.
Die Arbeit ist gut organisiert.
Und ich brauche nicht, am Wochenende zu arbeiten.
Sehr schön.
Nein, da habe ich keinen Stress.
Darf ich Ihre Familienstadt fragen?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und ich habe eine Tochter, die ist 25 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch leider schon Probleme mit dem Übergewicht.
Übergewicht.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Die Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt.
Die ist soweit noch ganz gesund.
Sie hat etwas Gelenkräumer.
Und sie hat auch Alterszucker.
Und der Vater, der ist mit 65 Jahren alt.
Er ist mit 65 Jahren am Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Er hatte schon mit 60 Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Und dann eben mit 65 Jahren wieder einen Herzinfarkt.
Und da ist er dran verstorben.
Ist er am Herzinfarkt mit 65 verstorben?
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie auch die Schwester?
Ja, ein Bruder ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Er hat auch hohen Blutbrug.
Vor einem Jahr hatte er einen Herzkatheter.
Und da hat er so einen Röhrchen gekriegt.
Ich glaube, das heißt Stent.
Ja, Stent.
Stent-Implantation.
Okay, Frau Walter.
Wir gehen regelmäßig zur Kontrolle beim Frauenarzt.
Ja, nicht so ganz regelmäßig.
Alle drei Jahre vielleicht.
Ich war jetzt seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich in den nächsten Monaten
mir wieder einen Termin geben lassen.
Ja, das wäre super, weil Sie sollten eine Versorgung machen müssen.
Machen Sie bitte das.
Ja, das wäre super.
Das wäre super.
Machen Sie bitte das.
Okay, Frau Walter, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Was ist das? Was kann das sein?
Ja, ich verstehe es sehr.
Aber eine genaue Diagnose stellen zu können,
müssen wir noch ein paar Untersuchungen genau durchführen.
Ja, ich werde diese Körperlische untersuchen,
dann einige Bulutabnahme und EKG und Elektro-Kardiografie
und auch ultra-schal Unterrichtung,
herz ultra-schal Unterrichtung,
am Ende der diese Untersuchungen können wir darüber widersprechen.
Ich kann Ihnen eine genaue Diagnose sagen,
aber zurzeit das ist sehr früh.
Okay, gut, können wir so machen.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie sagten, dass Sie vor einer Woche
unter einem ähnlichen Beschwerd gelitten haben?
Ja, vor ungefähr zwei Wochen war das.
Aber nicht so stark wie heute.
Was haben Sie dabei gemacht?
Was war ich in der Arbeit, kurz vor der Mittagspause,
und da habe ich mich erstmal ganz ruhig hingesetzt und abgewartet.
Ich war seitdem aber muss ich auch ehrlich sagen,
noch nicht beim Arzt.
Ich habe dem Arzt das nicht berichtet.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt,
nur Impfstatus nicht gefragt.
Ich denke, alles Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit Ausland?
Im Ausland?
Haben Sie eine Reise eingestellt?
Ja, ich war in letzter Zeit, ich war im letzten Herbst,
war ich für zwei Wochen in Marokko.
Aber das war im letzten Herbst, also vor sechs Monaten.
Haben Sie eine Beine geschwollene Beine?
Ja, manchmal sind die Beine abends schon etwas geschwollene,
aber morgen sind sie dann wieder deutlich dünner.
Danke.
Als Erster, Herr Schäfer, können wir anfangen?
Ja, gerne.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Abend.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich,
wo wir gerne eine neue Patientin Ihnen vorstellen?
Hab ich.
Ja, Frau Henelore Walter ist eine 55-jährige Patientin,
die sich bei uns wegen seit zwei Stunden bestehend
durchgeführt, dispnet und schmerzend hinter dem Sternum.
Retro-Sternum?
Ja, Retro-Sternum, Schmerzend,
die sich bei uns vorgestellt haben,
dass sie sich bei uns vorgegeben haben,
bein stitcht, aber.
Und Südam,
teilte sie mit, dass vor ungefähr zwei Wochen
sie ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt haben.
Okay.
Dagegen nehmen sie eine Spray probiert und diese Medikamente hat ihr etwas ein bisschen geholfen.
Ja, sie hat einen Spray von ihrem Ehemann ausprobiert?
Ja, richtig von ihrem Ehemann ausprobiert.
Er hat den Mund gesprüht oder sublingual verabreicht hat mit einer leichten Besserung.
Ja.
Und der Patientin zufolge sein, die folgenden Begleitzentrumen aufgefallen.
Ja, vertigo und nozia und einmalige vomitus.
Okay.
Hat ihr über Palpitationen geklagt?
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie klackte über auch Arithmi und sie hat gefüllt das ihr Herz ein bisschen unregionalmäßig schläge.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Vitalparameter kontrolliert?
Ja, ich habe die alle Vitalparameter kontrolliert.
Ja, gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten bei der Patientin in der Risikokonstellation?
Ja, ich denke, dass sie hat ein bisschen Risiko, Konstellation.
Sie hat sehr große Familienanahmnese.
Eine positive Familienanahmnese?
Ja, positive Familienanahmnese und sie hat Adipositas und hat Arteriehypertone, Diabetes mellitus und auch Hypercholesterinämie.
Okay.
Ja, sie hat viele Prädisposan und Risikofaktionen.
Ja, okay.
Und raucht die Patientin?
Ja, auch.
Sie hat auch eine Prädisposanfaktor. Sie raucht seit 25 Jahren halbe Packung Zigaretten täglich und entspritzt sie über 25 Packers.
Okay.
Und sie trinkt einmal, aber in einer Woche ein Glas Wein.
Gibt es eine familiäre Vorgeschichte?
Ja, ihr Vater ist mit 65 Jahren Corona-Karriere verstorben.
New York-Kart infakt?
New York-Kart infakt verstorben.
Und ihre Mutter leidet an Diabetes mellitus und Romatuitatritis.
Okay.
Und auch ihr Bruder leidet an Corona-Herz-Arterien-Krankheit.
Er würde eine Stand-Implantation durchschiffet werden.
Ja, bei ihm ist vor zwei Jahren ein oder vor einem Jahr ein Stand-Anistent gekommen.
Ja.
Ist die Patientin operiert worden in ihrem Leben?
Ja, als sie Kind war, ist sie wegen Appendicitis operiert worden.
Und Kind erfolgte eine Appendectomy?
Ja.
Wie ist es noch weitere Operationen?
Vor sechs Jahren ist sie wegen Cholalitis operiert worden.
Cholatistektomie.
Ja.
Vor sechs Jahren wegen Cholalitis.
Okay.
Ja.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, die Annamnistischen Angaben doyten am ehesten auf eine akut Coronasendrom hin.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch kommen herzunsoficient Pulmoner,
Ambuli, ja, in Betracht.
Ja.
Wir müssen auch diese Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Können auch epigastrische oder gastrointestinale?
Auf Geschlecht.
Ja.
Ja, Pyrosis, desbeginn, das ist eine...
Okay, also denke auch die Differentialdiagnose ist sicherlich mehr so,
wie Sie sie geschildert haben, aber man sollte zumindest auch akute Oberbaussymptomatik ausgießen.
Aber primär glaube ich auch, eine kardiale Ursache sollte primär ausgeschlossen werden,
weil das für die Patientin sicherlich auch vital bedrohlich sein kann.
Ja, Sie hat momentan... ja, Arithmi.
Ja, Sie hat Arithmi und Sie haben die WG-Schwöhnung gleich kontrolliert, sehr gut.
Und wir müssen jetzt schauen, so ein bisschen spricht eventuell, was zumindest für eine Coronareherzerkrankung.
Sie ist leicht nitropositiv, schildert Sie das wohl.
Sie hat wohl wahrscheinlich ein Nitrospray bekommen.
Wir wissen nicht genau, ob das preparat ist.
Das hat sie leider wohl nicht mitgebracht vom Ehemann, sondern nur zu Hause genommen.
Das spricht dafür, man muss jetzt schauen, was die Arithmin machen, aber da wird sie jetzt herüberwacht am Monitor.
Und Sie leiten jetzt die Primärdiagnostik ein, akut Labor mit den dementsprechenden Parametern.
Und ich denke, Sie muss auf unsere Überwachungsstation auf alle Fälle.
Ja, richtig.
Wir müssen Intensivstation überwachen.
Ja, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr systematisch, sehr ruhig gemacht und haben sich auch gut Zeit gelassen.
Es ist jetzt erstmal nicht schlimm, wenn die Impfungen jetzt nicht aufgeführt wurden, aber die anderen Fragen,
denke ich, haben Sie gut abgedeckt und denken Sie dran nur in der Umsetzung auch,
dass Sie dann eben so Begriffe wie Brustbeinschmerz oder hinter dem Brustbein dann eben retro-sternaler Schmerz erwähnen gegenüber jetzt dem Oberarzt.
Oder die Gallenblasen-OP als Cholizistektomie.
Aber die anderen Begriffe, denke ich, haben Sie sehr gut erwähnt und auch gebracht, das fand ich sehr gut.
Ja, aus meiner Sicht denke ich, war das gut.
Wann haben Sie denn Prüfungen?
15. Juni.
Ja, dann bestehen jetzt ja noch einige Tage Zeit, um vielleicht nochmal an die Fachausdrücke zu denken,
dass Sie sich die einfach in der Zeit, Sie werden dann mehr Zeit haben, sich auf dieses Oberarztgespräch vorzubereiten.
Das war jetzt heute Abend ja sehr kurz.
Aber würde ich gleich immer hinschreiben, Gallenblasen-OP dahinter, mal wegen Cholizistektomie oder Appendektomie
und gar nicht so umständlich umschreiben in der Kindheit wegen Appendizitis-Appendektomie,
sondern am Reich das, glaube ich, als Kind erfolgt da eine Appendektomie,
mit komplikationslosen Verlauf vielleicht zu sagen.
Das reicht aus und dann haben Sie das wesentlich erwähnt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Zustand nach im Alter von acht Jahren eine Appendektomie.
Ja, im Alter von acht Jahren erfolgte eine Appendektomie
und vor sechs Jahren erfolgte eine Cholizistektomie wegen Cholilitiasis.
Dann sind diese beiden Felder schon mal abgedeckt.
Was Sie, sehe ich jetzt gerade, was Sie eventuell noch erwähnen sollten,
es besteht bei der Patientin auch eine diabetesche Rethinopathie
und Zustand nach zweimaliger Laserung.
Es ist zwar jetzt für diese Hauptdiagnose,
und wir sind ja Richtung kardialer Diagnose jetzt nicht erstmal so ganz erheblich,
aber wenn der Oberarzt eine genaue Schilderung erwähnen möchte,
sollten Sie das auch möglichst erwähnen.